to win the Guinness report I had to sit
for 32 hours straight
it was challenging but my determination
kept me going
the end result was lovely
now I have one Guinness and two link
records under my name
I showed the same determination while
taking the PMP examination
I cleared it with the help of Simply
love scores the end result I became the
Enterprise head with a 16 salary hike
hey I am Dr venkatesh natarajan I have
almost two decades of experience after
working with various organizations in
the sales sector in India in 2021 I
decided to move to Kenya I joined the
coffee cat limited as the head of
managed Services sales coming from a
sales background I had a very little
experience and knowledge about the
various processes that are followed
there in my new role I wanted to improve
my performance at work and I thought
being PMP certified would make my
portfolio very strong
choosing simply learn was easy I had
already taken a 90 year certification of
Simply learned and was aware of their
teaching methods
now I am well equipped with all relevant
skill sets PMP has actually helped me
understand the people domain and process
domain which has been really helpful for
me as soon as I became PMP certified I
was able to crack a great job offer I
got this MMC job with a good salary hike
it was an amazing experience
in my life so far I have gathered many
experiences I do have a PhD degree in
information technology but the one that
achieve is the most is breaking records
in 2017 I registered my name in the
Guinness Book of World Records for
singing continuously for 32 hours
the same year I got the Linker records
for the same
my first slim car was in 2016 for
continuous DJ
my motto is to keep becoming better with
each passing day if you have a
determination and passion upskilling and
gaining the right skill sets can help
you break any record you want